parmi les 28 ministres une innovation
une première à ministre du tourisme en
tout cas à ce jour on estime que 9
millions et demi d'allemands de l'est
c'est-à-dire 60% de la population ont
obtenu leur visa pour aller faire un
petit tour à l'ouest la quasi totalité
en effet a choisi de demeurer à l'est
exemple ces jeunes artistes qui sont qui
ont été rencontrés lors d'un concert de
rock le rock à berlin-est ce n'est pas
fréquent et on ne peut pas non plus le
film est très souvent c'est donc tout
l'intérêt du reportage d'hélène risacher
et embrasse perrin
ce sont des motivations personnelles qui
nous font rester la famille les amis
mais surtout à mon avis on peut essayer
ici de faire ce qu'on a envie de faire
même contre le régime
c'est à chacun de se déterminer mais il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ne supportait
plus on les a tellement tromper nous on
ne peut pas blâmer ces gens s'ils sont
partis c'est leur choix ils étaient
pressés ils ont voulu tenter leur chance
à l'ouest tolérance à l'égard de ceux
qui partent ou parfois reproche sous
jacent la jeunesse d'allemagne de l'est
qui a choisi de rester en rda a encore
de l'espoir
bien sûr ils ont couru voir l'ouest dès
qu'ils ont pu lui sont revenus chez les
artistes on connaissait déjà
grâce à leur métier les musiciens
avaient déjà voyagé en europe
un temps d'avant ce qui leur a permis de
commencer à réfléchir sur l'opposition
politique et sur l'avenir d'un nouveau
socialisme est-allemand
car ici le modèle de l'ouest ne séduit
pas complètement la plupart des gens ici
veulent vivre dans un système socialiste
je pense que c'est une bonne alternative
au capitalisme
il y a vraiment beaucoup de bonnes
choses ici et avec un petit peu plus de
liberté ce sera bien désunie si nous les
musiciens nous connaissons l'europe
il est ici la relation entre les gens
sont plus humains ya de l'émotion de la
solidarité
si on arrive à créer de nouveau
socialisme dans ce pays
ça sera mieux qu'à l'ouest la question
est de savoir si le communisme a encore
une justification pour survivre ici est
effectif à mon avis ce qu'il faut
d'abord se rénover et si ça ne marche
pas il faudra changer tout le système
dans sa demande plus de compétition
entre les gens mais une vraie qui
favorise la créatinine guide quand flash
cette pseudo émulation socialiste qui
n'apportent rien aux travailleurs et qui
ne motive pas les gens c'est ça qui fait
baisser de plus en plus la productivité
socke empêchement ils savent ce qu'ils
ne veulent plus pas encore très bien ce
qu'ils veulent
ces jeunes d'allemagne de l'est ont
décidé de laisser d'abord une chance à
leurs gouvernements pour amorcer les
réformes mais leur vigilance demeure et
leur impatience grandi de prendre part à
la construction d'une nouvelle
démocratie